Eric something you just said to us
off-camera was that when you do see
students again sometimes out in the the
public arena that they'll say you know I
always remember you encouraged me to
write badly with pride and how it worked
for them can we talk about that
yeah sure every time I walk into the
class the first evening all our classes
are evening evening classes then in the
new class the first year people there
for the first semester and I walk in and
they're chattering away and trying to
get to know each other and so forth but
they haven't you know really had any
anything to do with me yet and I walk in
it was always weird and creepy because
as soon as I walk in deathly silence
falls everybody's waiting so I look very
austere and serious and I walk to the
whiteboard and I write on the whiteboard
and very very large letters write badly
with pride and then they laugh everybody
everybody laughs and it cuts the ice and
you know it works that way and I turn
around and I smile and I say yes but I'm
not kidding for it is a critical
importance for writers to permanently
give themselves permission to write
badly if writer's block is all about
expecting and demanding oneself
perfection anything any word any
sentence it's gotta be great it's got to
be great
no that way lies right early death you
do that you'll end up freezing so solid
you'll never write again it is exactly
the opposite writing is a craft it's a
craft and how do you how do you
participate in a craft it's a craft that
it's you that exercise with words and it
is like in I don't know statuary or
something you start up with a big gooey
pile of wet clay and you started mush it
you get your hands dirty you know you
get down in the mud and your mush it and
squish it then you start making choices
about as you shape it the
pieces you're not going to need and so
forth and you go from there but you
start out with mess that's what we do as
writers we start with mess and then we
make choices first hundreds of choices
and then thousands of choices and before
we're done tens of thousands of
individual choices have been made but
you cannot make choices and you cannot
see what or choose what direction you
want your story to go in or have you
wanted to develop unless you have a pile
of words on the page so we have
exercises sometimes just let's try it
that's right as badly as we know how and
it's funny you read them aloud everybody
gets a laugh it's cancer and what they
find out is even when they are trying to
write badly because that's what we're
doing it's this little exercise it still
comes out funny it's still it's it's not
bad in other words they're they're funny
they're cute they're weird they're
quippy but even writing badly they're
not really writing that badly at all
you